this brain teaser is a bit of a classic
and i'm sure a bunch of you have heard
it before but i wanted to include this
in the brain teaser playlist that i'm
making right now because this one is
actually a good build up and a bit of a
nice warm-up session for a slightly
harder brain teaser that deals with
people telling the truth and lying so
this one we could call it the
the you know the
truth teller and the liar truth teller
and liar so we're on some type of
adventure quest and we get to a fork in
a road right so i have or let's say that
there's uh
two doors let's make it that's even
better so there's two doors
and
i've gotten to i guess i've gotten to
the end of my adventure quest and i know
that my treasure is behind one of these
two doors unfortunately behind the other
door is immediate actually not immediate
slow and painful death and all of the
misery in the world so i want to pick
the door carefully
and besides his doors there are two
people sitting there
there's one guy that looks like this
and then there's another guy that looks
like this and i know for a fact
the the gods of brain teasers have come
and told me
that both of these guys know
which door has the treasure and both of
these guys know which door has the um
the unbelievable
despair that that would ensue if i open
that door
so i both of these guys know which door
i should be opening and i also know and
both of them know that one of them
always tells the truth
one is
always honest
always honest and then one of them
always lies
always
one always lies
and the problem is
i don't know who's who
so and i only have one chance to one
obviously i can't just open the door and
close it if i open the wrong door the
despair will come out and kill and and
you know all of the pain will happen and
i can only ask one question of one of
them
to decide which door to open so remember
they both know the correct answer but
one of them always lies one of them
always tells the truth and i only have
one question
to ask of one of them
so the brain teaser is is what question
do you ask
who do you ask it to do you ask it to
the green guy or to the brown guy
and then what do you do
based on what they tell you
so that is the the problem description
and i will now give you the solution so
if you don't want the solution i
encourage you not to i think if you
think about this one for maybe 20 or 30
minutes or at most a day sometimes when
you sleep on a brain teaser you it might
come to you so i encourage you to do
that so pause it stop it whatever don't
listen anymore because here is the
solution
so what you do is
i mean you don't know who's who so it's
kind of it's not like there's a correct
answer on who you ask a question of but
what you do is you ask either of the
people
you ask them
what door
or what would the other guy say
what would
the other
guy say
is the correct door to open
correct door
to open
so let's think about this so i could ask
this guy what would the i'm asking the
green guy what would this guy say is the
correct door to open now what happens if
if this guy
tells the truth
if this guy tells the truth
then this guy is the liar
right
and if
and so he will actually tell me what
this guy would tell me to do
and the liar
oh it is
is the correct right so
if i if what would the other guy say is
the correct door to open right so if
this guy if you were to tell him the
correct door to open he would tell you
the incorrect door to open right
so when you ask this guy
what would that guy say he'll be honest
about what this guy would say and since
he's a liar he would tell you the
incorrect door so the answer to this
question you would get the incorrect
door
incorrect door would be the answer to
that question
if this guy's a truth teller and this
guy is a liar now what happens if it's
the other way around what if i ask this
guy and he happens to be the liar
so this guy's a liar
this guy's the truth teller
so the liar
will he he can't help himself he will
lie
so he knows that this other guy is the
truth teller there right there's only
two of them there he knows this guy is
the truth teller and he knows that this
guy when asked will say the correct door
to open so if you asked if you happen to
be lucky you asked this guy the correct
door he would tell it to you
this guy
will lie
and
he knows let's say that this is the
correct door let's say this is the
correct door door door number two is the
correct door
whoops
i somehow zoomed in so let's say that
door number two is the correct door
if you ask this guy directly you say oh
yeah door number two that's you'll find
all your happiness in behind door number
two
now if this guy is a liar he knows that
the truth teller will say door number
two
but he's a liar so he'll tell you door
number one
so once again if i ask the same question
of the liar
i still get the incorrect door
right so no matter who i ask this
question to
their answer will be the wrong door
right the incorrect door or you know the
door that i get all of the pain from
so what you do is you ask this question
what would the other guy say is the
correct door to open and no matter who
you asked that to they're going to
answer the incorrect door and then so
you do the opposite
so i asked this guy ask mr green guy
what would mr brown guy say
is the correct door to open and if mr
green guy says oh
open door number
green guy will say brown guy will tell
you to open door number one
well a green guy says that brown guy
will tell me to open door number one
then i should open up door number two
and likewise if green guy says brown guy
will say to open door number two
then i should open door number one
anyway that's a nice warm up brain
teaser for the next one i'm gonna give
you